- Hey, Texas, yip, yip!
So when we say "Southern Style Barbecue,"
it's a lot of different regions that
have very specific styles, right?
But in general, the main
thing you gotta know
is oh fucking delicious.
- All you can eat Korean
barbecue you get like
a lot of side dishes and stuff, but like
I feel like the main focus
for this is like the meat.
- I'm vegetarian so I'm just going
to be eating everything but the meat.
- I'm here to eat, you know what I mean?
I'm hungry.
- I'm ready for it.
See, I get so turned on by meat, it's bad.
Sausage, these are hot links!
- Should I--
- Yeah, go for it.
- I feel like it's not
gonna be that spicy.
- The skin is really tough
which I'm not used to.
- What are you used to, like hot dogs?
- Yeah.
- Hot dogs are supposed
to be like soft and chewy.
This is kinda crunchy.
- That was good.
- Yeah?
- Yeah.
- I believe you.
- That's actually pretty
spicy, I'm impressed.
- They're not like super spicy.
As a Korean person, I'm used
to like super spicy food.
- Yeah, I approve of this, this is good.
- Oh, you like it!
- Yeah.
- Yeah!
Alright, we're gonna go to the brisket.
Now as a Texan, brisket
is for me where it's at.
- Do you want some of this?
- Oh, I'm OK, thank you.
- What's a brisket?
- It's a cow chest, the cow pecs.
It's like (grunts).
- It just looks like a piece of bark
that fell off a tree.
- (laughing) It does.
- (mumbles) bite into it, stop cutting.
- You can have that, I'll have this.
- I'm enjoying this.
- I'm afraid to open my
mouth now 'cause I have
like a piece of meat like--
- [Woman] I see it.
- Definitely gotta bring
my floss for this one.
- Do we put barbecue sauce on this?
- Some barbecue styles come with
sauce smothered on top
and some come with it on the side.
I'm from Texas so I do it from the side.
From what I understand then, you've never
had barbecue ribs.
- I feel like I've had some from
like Outback Steakhouse.
- Oh (beep) no!
- I feel like the true test of this is how
well the meat falls off the bone.
- Oh, it just comes right off.
- That's a good sign, right?
- Yeah, that's a great sign.
- Mm.
- That looks so good.
- It is so good.
- You know what animal this is, right?
- This is pig meat, right?
- Cow?
- No, pig, you idiot!
- This is like love at first bite.
This is like really good.
- That's really tender.
- That's really good.
- Oh my god.
- Now you got two of 'em.
- I'll just leave this here on your plate.
- That pork rib is perfectly sized
and that fat on it is just delicious.
Mm, can't get better than that pork fat.
- This is delicious, but I don't think
anything compares to Korean barbecue.
- It's definitely good
enough to eat more than once.
- Here's the thing.
In the world, Southern
United States barbecue
and Korean barbecue are the best.
You gather around like
the pit or the grill
and you have like a cookout or smokeout
and you have all the like
neighborhood people gather.
It's like more than just a
cuisine, it's a tradition.
Look, you're still going for it.
- Yeah, and I just ate lunch.
(chuckling)